[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: Hi, everybody.
I hope you can hear me.
Give me a thumbs up if you can.
Good.
I see them coming through.
So we're going to get started.
So getting back to
what we've been doing.
We've been talking
about space complexity.
Measures how much memory
the algorithm requires
or various problems require.
And we defined the space
complexity classes,
space f of n and
non-deterministic space
f of n, the polynomial space
and non-deterministic space
classes, and gave some
examples and so on.
And today we're going to pick
up where we left off last time.
One of the examples,
which is going
to be an important one for
us, concerns this latter DFA
problem.
So I'm going to go over that
again, give a little bit more
emphasis to the space
analysis, which I got
some questions about last time.
And then we are going
to move on from there
and prove Savitch's
theorem and then
talk about a complete
problems for PSPACE
and show that this problem TQBF,
which we introduced last time,
is actually a PSPACE
complete problem.
But all in due course.
A little bit of review.
So we defined what we
mean by a Turing machine
to run in a certain
amount of space.
That means it uses
at most f of n.
If it's running in space f of
n, uses at most f of n cells,
tape cells, on every
input of length n.
And similarly, a
non-deterministic Turing
machine does the same.
But in addition to that, the
non-deterministic machine
has to halt on every
branch of its computation.
And each branch
of its computation
has to use at most that
bounded amount of tape cells.
So we're going to be talking
about non-deterministic space
computation today as well.
It's going to be relevant to us.
So we defined the
classes, as I mentioned,
and the polynomial
and the PSPACE
and non-deterministic
PSPACE classes.
And this is how we believe
they relate to one another.
The classes coNP and NP as well.
And of course, as I
mentioned last time,
there are some very major
unsolved problems in this area.
So everything could
conceivably collapse down
to P, which would, of
course, be very surprising.
But we don't know how
to prove otherwise.
And the big theorem that
we're going to prove today
is that polynomial space and
non-deterministic polynomial
space actually do collapse
down to each other.
And being the same class.
So in contrast with the
situation that we believe
to be the case for
time complexity
where we believe converting
non-deterministic
to deterministic gives an
exponential increase for space
complexity, it only gives
a squaring increase,
as we'll see.
So any questions on any of this?
We will just march into a little
review of this latter problem.
So reviewing some
of the notation.
And let me emphasize that.
So the big theorem we're
going to be proving today
is that PSPACE and
NPSPACE are equal.
And also we're
going to be talking
about PSPACE completeness.
But both of those
involve proving theorems.
In the first case,
Savitch's theorem
that converting
non-deterministic to
deterministic
spaces is squaring.
And in the second case, proving
that TQBF is PSPACE complete.
Both of those theorems can be
thought of as generalizations
of this theorem here that
the latter DFA problem can
be done in the deterministic
polynomial space or n squared
space.
So it really pays
to try to understand
how the proof of
this theorem works.
Because in a sense, this theorem
is a more concrete version
of what we're going to be seeing
in those other two theorems
in a somewhat more
abstract form.
So I like understanding things
in a more concrete way first.
So that's why this is a good
example to start out with.
But really in the
end of the day,
it's the same
proof just repeated
for those three theorems.
So this is really three
for the price of one.
Three theorems, one proof here.
So you're going to be seeing
the same proof repeated
three times but in different
levels of abstraction.
So let's review again.
I know some of you got it,
but maybe some of you didn't.
And let's just try to be
clear on the algorithm
to solve the ladder DFA problem.
So if you remember, first of
all, let me just jump on ahead.
The ladder problem is--
a ladder, first of
all, is a sequence
of strings that change one
symbol at a time that perhaps
connect, go from one
string to another.
So you're going to
go from work to play,
changing one symbol at a time.
So we gave an example
of this or you
can easily come up with
an example of doing this.
But the computational
problem is can you do it?
Can you get from this
string to that string
and stay within a
certain language?
So it might be the
language of English words
or it might be the
language of all strings
that some specific
DFA recognizes.
So it might be
all of the string.
These might all be
strings that some DFA
accepts or might be English
words or some other rule.
And so that's what
we mean by trying
to test if there's a ladder.
And so the ladder problem
is, well, I don't think I
wrote down the ladder
problem itself.
But the bounded ladder problem
is basically the same idea.
You're given the DFA.
You're given the
strings u and v.
And now this is
the bounded version
of the problem where
I'm going to give you
a limit on the number
of steps you can take.
So I'm illustrating that here.
So you're going to be given a b.
And you want to say, can
I get from this string
to that string within b steps?
And we had a notation
for writing that.
Going from u to v, if there's
a ladder that connects
u to v within at most b steps.
And so the bounded
ladder problem,
which I'm introducing
because I'm
going to be aiming toward
a recursive algorithm
to solve this problem is can
I get from u to v by a ladder,
changing one symbol at a time,
where each string along the way
is accepted by b, and
I'm only allowed b steps.
Little b steps.
So that is the
computational problem
that I'm going to be
solving with the algorithm
that I'm going to describe.
So the algorithm
I'm going to call
BL for bounded ladder problem.
And here is the input.
And the algorithm
is, first of all,
going to look to
see if b equals 1.
If I'm just trying to get
from u to v in a single step.
In that case, it's a
very simple problem,
because you want to test,
obviously, that u and v are
accepted by the automaton.
And they just have to
differ in one place.
And then you have a
very simple one step
ladder that takes u to v.
So for the case b equals 1,
it's very simple.
For larger values
of b, we're going
to solve the problem
recursively in terms
of smaller values of b.
So for b greater than 1, we're
going to recursively test.
If you're trying to solve the
problem can I get from u to v,
instead we're going to try
each possible halfway through.
We don't know that
it's halfway through.
So we're just going to
try each possible string.
And we're going to test can we
get from u, the initial string,
to that new string, that w,
in half the number of steps.
And can I get to
the final string
v in half the number of steps?
If I can do that, then
I can get from u to v
the total number of steps b.
So I'm just going to
try to do this one w
at a time for every possible w.
This is going to be very
expensive in terms of time,
but we're not worried
about time right now.
We're trying to cut down
on the amount of space
that we're using.
And this is going to be
a big savings in space.
Let's not worry about the
division, b over 2 here.
All of the divisions,
we're going
to be seeing this several times
going forward in the lecture,
we'll think of them rounding up.
But I'm not going to
make the notation look
cumbersome by writing
that every time.
OK.
So here we go.
Here is some candidate w string,
which is halfway through.
Recursively test.
Can I get from the starting
string to that w and from w
to that ending string?
If I can, if I find
such a w, then I accept.
And if I try all possible w and
I never manage to find a way
to make both the top
and the bottom work,
then I know I cannot get
from the starting string
to the ending string
within b steps.
And so I reject.
And now I'm going to solve
the original unbounded ladder
problem by simply
putting the biggest
possible bound into the
bounded ladder problem.
And that's this value t, which
gives the very trivial bound
of the total number
of possible strings
that I can write down within my
length m that I'm working with.
So this if sigma is the
alphabet of these strings,
it's just sigma to the m.
That's all possible strings.
Of course, that's going to be
a maximum size on the ladder.
So now how much
space does this take?
And I think this is where
people got a little bit lost
in the lecture last time.
So I'm going to try
to animate this.
I don't know if that's
going to help or not.
But in the end of
the day, you're
just going to have to think
through how do you account
for the cost of this recursion.
But the main thing,
to start off,
you have to make sure you
understand the algorithm.
And if you get
from here to there,
we're going to try
all possible midpoints
and then solve the upper part
and the lower part recursively,
reusing the space.
That's the way we're
going to get a saving.
By solving this problem,
reusing the space
that we use to
solve this problem.
So I'm going to try to show
this to you on actually
how the space gets used
on the Turing machine.
You can kind of think
of here's the input
and then after that is going to
be the stack for the recursion.
If you're not that familiar
with how to implement recursion,
it doesn't really matter.
But you can just think about
what the algorithm needs
to keep track of.
And so as it's trying
every possible w,
so just in order like
an odometer, just
trying every possible
string, eventually maybe it
finds a string that's
in the language that
hears an English word, one
of the first English words
of length 4 that
you might run into.
And so now it makes sense,
actually, to do the recursion.
So that's all.
Every time you're going
to have to have a register
or a location on the tape where
you're going to be writing down
those different w's.
So let's say it's over here.
And we're just
going to go through.
I hope that's not too
small for you to see.
That's really where that
action is happening.
And finally, maybe you
got to the string w.
Now you're going to try
to do the recursion.
So here as you're doing the
recursion on the top half
again, you're going
to be cutting--
you're going to be finding a
new w for the intermediate point
just solving this upper
problem where we're testing
if I can get from work to able.
Later I'm going to have to deal
with getting from able to play.
Good.
So here, again, we're
going to be fixing able,
fixing the first w.
We're going to try
every possible way
of getting from the start
string to that middle string.
So we're going to try
every possible thing here.
Eventually maybe we find some
other string in the language.
We get down to the string book.
And that's all
going to get stored.
You can't forget
the string able.
But now we're going
to use some more space
to store those candidates.
So that's a second version
of w deeper in the recursion.
So here we're going to be
triangle to possible strings
here.
Again, eventually we
get to some string book.
And if that succeeds in getting
us from work to able via book,
now we're going to jump
down to do the bottom half,
to see if I can get
from able to play
as a separate problem, which
gets solved in the same space.
So now here we're going to try
all these possibilities getting
from able to play.
Maybe call is the right
intermediate string there.
And so now we're going
to erase the book
and now we're going
to solve the lower sub
problem in the same location.
I hope this is helpful.
This was a lot of work
making these animations.
So the point of all
this is every time
we go down the level
of the recursion,
there's another
register whose size
is big enough to hold one
of the strings, is needed.
And that register
gets reused times
throughout as we're going
through this recursion.
So anyway, I hope
that's helpful.
Anyway.
So each level of the recursion
adds another order in
to record the w.
And so you have to do--
how many levels do we get.
Well, the depth of
the recursion is
going to be how
many times we end up
having to divide this picture
in half until we get down to 1.
And so the height of
this when we start off
is going to be basically
an exponential in m. m
is roughly the size of n.
So when you take the log of
that, you're going to get--
you're going to pull
down the exponential.
So it's going to be
order m or, which is,
again, roughly the
same size as the input.
m is like half the input
because the whole input is u
and v. m is just the size of u.
And so each level
requires order n,
and the depth is going
to be order n deep.
The log of the initial
height of this ladder.
And so the total space used is
going to be order n squared.
So why don't we
just take a minute?
I'm happy to spend a little
time going through this,
either the algorithm's
correctness,
understanding recursion,
or understanding the space
analysis.
If there's any
question that you feel
you can ask that would be
clarifying for you, jump in.
I'll set aside a few minutes
just to answer questions here.
So I've got a question here.
In step five, why
do we reject if all
fail instead of just one fails?
Well, here, so remember
what we're trying to do.
We're trying to say can I
get from u to v in b steps?
The way I'm going
to be doing that is
trying every possible
intermediate string w.
If I find some w
which does not work,
that doesn't mean
that there's not
some other w which might work.
All I need is one
w for which I can
get from u to w in half
the number of steps and w
to v in half the
number of steps.
So I'm going to try
every possible w.
If any one of them is
good, then I can accept.
If any one of them
succeeds where
I can get from u to
w in half the steps
and to w to v in half
the steps, then I
know I can get from u to v
in the full number of steps.
So I only need to find one.
If one particular
one doesn't work,
I'll just go on to the next one.
OK.
This is a good question.
Do we have to save
the word book?
So once we succeed in
getting from work to able,
let's say via book, do
we need to save that word
book anywhere?
No.
All we need to remember
is that we've succeeded
in getting from work to able.
We don't need to
remember book anymore.
We just remember
that we've succeeded.
And that is by virtue of
where we are in the algorithm.
If we have succeeded,
then we move
on to the second recursion,
second call, recursive call.
So we found some way to do it.
So we found some
intermediate point
which succeeds for this one.
So we move on to that one.
We don't have to keep
any of that work anymore.
All you have to do
is remember, yes,
I can get from work to able
in half the number of steps.
Now all that's left is
to get from able to play
in half the number of steps.
It doesn't matter how I got
to able in the first place.
So we don't have
to remember that.
That was a good question though.
So I think I understand this.
Before we replace the
value for book with call
with the work
involved to find call,
yeah, we have to check that
we can get from work to book
and book to able.
So we keep onto book while
we're working on the upper half.
And only when we've
finally succeeded
in getting from work to
able, let's say via book,
then you can throw a book away.
But while you're working on
the upper half, you try book,
you try different strings of
length four until one of them
works.
I'm not sure.
Somebody is asking me about
breadth first search and depth
for search.
I'm not sure I see it.
I'm not sure that's going to
be a helpful way of thinking
about this.
So I'm not going to
answer that right now.
But you can ask that
offline later if you want.
Why is the recursion depth
log t instead of log m?
Well, how high is this thing?
Initially it's t high.
But every time
we're doing a level,
we're calling the recursion,
we're cutting t in half.
I'm solving this
in general for b,
but we starting off with b equal
to t. t is the maximum size.
So initially this
is going to be t,
and then it's going to be
t over 2, then t over 4.
So it's going to be log t
levels before we get down to 1.
Yeah.
So somebody is
asking, can we think
of this as a memory stack?
Yes, this is like--
that's the way
your typical
implementation of recursion
is kind of with a stack, where
you push when you make a call
and you pop when you
return from the call.
Is it possible that v can
appear during BL procedure on t?
Is it possible
that v can appear?
I'm not sure what that means.
It can reappear.
So I'm starting with
u to v. Is it possible
that v might be one of
these intermediate strings?
Yeah.
You're going to try every
possible intermediate stream
blindly.
Including v is one of them.
If you can reach v more
quickly, well, great.
I guess I have not dealt
with the issue of what
happens if you get to a--
technically it's
going to work out
because I'm allowing
the difference
to be in at most one place.
So even if you get
there early, you're
allowed to not change
anything, and that still
is a legal step in the ladder.
Yeah.
I don't see how to do this
from a bottom up perspective.
Somebody's is asking is there
a bottom up version of this.
I don't think so.
No, I don't think so.
All right.
Why don't we move on?
So now we're going to
see this proof again.
But this time we're
going to be proving
that you can convert
any NFA to a DFA
with only a squaring increase.
So really, well, let me
just put that up there.
So this is going to be
Savitch's theorem, that
among other things proves
that PSPACE equals NPSPACE.
So it says that you can convert
a non-deterministic machine
to a deterministic machine only
squaring the amount of space.
So you're comfortable
with this notation here.
Anything that you can do in f
of n space non-deterministically
you can do in f squared of
n based deterministically.
And we're going
to accomplish that
by converting an NTM
to a deterministic TM
but only squaring
the space used.
So n is going to
convert it to an m.
And now this proof
is going to look
very similar to the proof
in the previous slide.
It's the same proof.
And the fact from the
previous slide about ladder
really is implied
by this, because we
had an easy algorithm to show
that the latter problem is
solvable in
non-deterministic, in NPSPACE.
So ladder problem was
easily shown to be in here.
If you remember, you
just basically guess
the steps of the ladder.
So non-deterministically,
you can easily check,
can I get from the
start to the end?
But Savitch's theorem
tells us that anything
you can do non-deterministically
in polynomial space you
can do deterministically
in polynomial space.
So what we showed in
the previous slide
follows from this
slide, but this slide
is really just a generalization
of the same proof.
Maybe I've said it
too many times now.
So we're going to
introduce a notation very
similar to the notation
we had last time.
But now we're
going to be talking
about simulating this
non-deterministic machine
with a deterministic machine.
And we're going to
take two configurations
of this non-deterministic
machine, ci and cj,
and say can I get from ci
to cj in at most b steps?
I'm going to have a notation.
Very similar to the notation
for the ladder where
I can get from this word
to that word in at most b
steps by a ladder.
Here can I get from
this word to that--
can I get from
this configuration
to that configuration
with at most
b steps of the Turing
machine's operation?
So these are two
configurations now of n.
So can n go from
this configuration ci
to that other
configuration cj but only
taking b steps along the way?
That's now the
computational problem
that I'm going to solve
for you with an algorithm.
And it's going to be a recursion
exactly like the previous one.
So n gets its input
the two configurations
ci and cj and the bound
b and want to check
can I get from i to j within b?
So now the picture is a little
different but very similar.
So instead of a
ladder appearing here,
it's really something
that's basically
a tableau for the
machine n where
I have an initial configuration
and an ending configuration.
This would happen to
be the starting point
for the whole
procedure if you're
testing whether n accepts w.
But we would be solving
this in general for any--
so that case, so I have the
start configuration of n on w
and the accepting configuration
or an accepting configuration.
But in general, what
I will be solving
is starting with
any configuration ci
and going to any
configuration cj.
So I want to test
can I get from ci
to cj within at most b steps.
So first of all, if b is 1, you
can just check that directly.
And now, again, we're
operating deterministically
to simulate the
non-deterministic machine.
So this is the
deterministic machine m.
So m can easily, if it's
given two configurations of n
and says, can I get
from the first one
to the second one in one step?
Well, that's an easy check.
You just lay out those
two configurations,
look at the n's transition
function, and say
is this a legal move for n?
Yes or no?
And you accept or
reject accordingly.
Now, if b is larger
than 1, you're
going to try all possible
intermediate configurations,
calling them c mid.
This was like the w from
the previous theorem.
This is all possible strings c--
all possible
configurations c mid.
And a configuration is
just going to be a--
so far so-- OK.
This is all possible.
Looked like my PowerPoint
crashed, but it seems OK.
This is all possible
configurations,
which is just a string
with a string of tape
symbols with a state
symbol appearing somewhere.
That's all it is.
Going to try all possible
configurations as candidate
middle configurations.
And say can I get from the upper
one to this candidate middle
one and from that middle one
to the lower one within half
the number of steps each time.
And solving that
problem recursively.
So I got a question here
about the possibility
of looping forever.
First of all, if n is
going to be looping,
I don't have to worry about
it, because I'm starting off,
I only need to simulate
machines that are deciders.
Because I'm trying to show
that any language in here
has to be accepted,
has to be decided
by some non-deterministic
machine.
So I'm not going to worry about
machines that are looping.
If they're looping, m may
misbehave in some way,
but that's not going
to be a problem for me.
So let's keep life simple.
Think about the deciders only.
So we're going to
recursively test here.
So that means I'm going to
try every possible middle,
see if I can get from the start
to the middle and the middle
to the end.
If both of them work after
I test them recursively,
then I'm going to accept.
If not, I'm going to continue.
And I reject if I try them all
and none of them have worked.
Then I know there's no way for
n to get from this configuration
to that configuration
in b steps.
And the overall picture, I
test whether n accepts w,
as I mentioned, by
starting with ci
is the start configuration and
cj is the accept configuration.
And now how big is t?
Because I need to calculate
a bound on how deep
the recursions are going to be.
So t here is going to
be the total number
of possible configurations.
If this is the whole thing, it
never repeats a configuration.
So this is going to be a
bound on how many steps
then can be taken.
And that's simply we
calculated this before.
It's the number of
states times the number
of head positions times the
number of tape contents.
And this is really going to
be the dominant consideration
anyway.
And so now each recursive
level, and maybe I
should have emphasized
this at the beginning,
how wide is this picture?
It's big enough to
store a configuration.
A configuration is
essentially a tape contents.
So that's going
to be f of n wide.
So each recursive level
stores one configuration.
Now the w costs f of
n space to write down.
And the number of
levels is going
to be the log of the initial
height, which is this.
So this is going to be
the dominating part of it.
So the log of this is going
to be, again, order f of n.
So each one takes f of
n space to write down.
The depth of the recursion
is going to be order f of n.
So the total is going to
be order f squared of n,
and that's how much
space this uses.
And that's the proof
of Savitch's theorem.
So yeah, so this is
a good point there.
Somebody asks can
there be multiple
accepting configurations.
I should have made the--
I forgot to say this and
I was just realizing it
as I was explaining it.
One of the things
I should have--
you can enforce that there
is just a single accepting
configuration.
This is kind of a
detail, so don't worry
about it if you don't want to.
But you can make sure that
there's a single accepting
configuration by telling
the machine when it accepts,
it should erase its
tape and move its head
into the left most cell in
the accept configuration.
So there's just going to be a
single accepting configuration
to worry about instead of having
to try multiple possibilities,
which you could do
in this algorithm,
but it would just
be annoying to have
to write that down that way.
So we often assume
there's just going
to be a single
accepting configuration
for these machines.
How do you know f of n?
So that's actually a little
bit of a delicate issue.
I mean, if you could
compute f of n,
the bound, which is,
for example, if it's
going to be a polynomial bound,
you can just compute f of n.
It's very easy to compute
n squared or n cubed.
And so you can just
compute that and then use
that as the size
of the registers
you're going to be writing down.
If you want to prove this
in general for f of n,
it's a little bit technical
to have to deal with it.
And I'm going to have to refer
you to the book on that one.
The book tells you how solve
this for a general f of n.
You basically have to try
every possible value from one
until it works.
And I'm afraid that's
going to derail
us trying to decipher that.
So let's not worry
about that aspect of it.
But you can handle
general f of n here.
You don't need to put
any conditions on f of n.
Can we go over this term here?
So we've seen this
term once before when
we talked about LBAs and
seeing that LBAs always--
we can solve the ALBA problem.
This is simply the number
of different configurations
the machine can have.
Because the
configuration is a state.
It's a head position and
a contents of the tape.
And this is the number
of each of those
that you can possibly have.
Number of states.
A head position, the size of
the tape of f of n is f of n.
So this is that many
different head positions.
And this is the number--
if d is the size of
the tape alphabet,
this is the number of tape
contents that you can have.
How is seeing if n accepts
w with this algorithm
convert a
non-deterministic Turing
machine to some
deterministic Turing machine?
Well, n is the
non-deterministic Turing.
So n is we're converting
non-deterministic Turing
machine n to deterministic
Turing machine m.
So m is a deterministic
simulator of n.
That's what this whole m is.
So if we can do this for any n,
then we've proved our theorem.
Why don't we defer.
I think I got through most
of the questions here.
If there's other
things, we can save them
for the coffee break,
which is coming soon.
I think we have one
more slide before that.
So I'm going to define
PSPACE completeness I think.
Yeah.
And then I think after
that we have the break.
So PSPACE completeness is
defined and very much inspired
similarly to NP completeness.
So a problem is PSPACE
complete if it's in NPSPACE
and every other member of
PSPACE is reducible to it
in polynomial time.
And we'll say a bit about
why we choose polynomial time
reducibility here.
So here's kind of a
picture of how PSPACE--
how complete problems relate
to their complexity classes.
So you kind of think of a
complete problem for a class.
It's kind of the hardest
problem in that class
because you can convert.
You can reduce any other
problem in that class
to the complete problem.
So here are the NP
complete problems.
Sort of the hardest for NP.
You have the PSPACE
complete problems,
kind of the hardest for PSPACE.
If an NP complete
problem goes into P,
that pulls down all of NP to P.
If any PSPACE complete problem
goes into P, it pulls
down all the PSPACE into P
by following the
chain of reductions,
because any PSPACE
problem is reducible
to the complete problem.
Which in turn if it's in P,
then everything goes into P.
So if you have a PSPACE
complete problem which is in P,
then all the PSPACE goes into P.
So why do we use polynomial time
reducibility instead of, say,
polynomial space reducibility
when we define this notion?
It's kind of a very
reasonable question.
But if you think about it, using
polynomial space reducibility
would be a terrible idea.
And we've seen this
phenomenon happen before.
Every two problems
in PSPACE are going
to be PSPACE reducible
to one another.
We haven't even defined
that notion yet,
but you can imagine
what it would be.
Because a PSPACE reduction
can solve the problem
for a problem in PSPACE.
And then it can direct its
answer anywhere that it likes.
So in general, when we
think about reductions,
the reduction should be not
capable of solving the problems
in the class.
Because if they could, then
every two problems in the class
would be reducible
to one another.
And then all
problems in the class
would be complete, because
everything in the class
would be reducible to any
one of the other problems.
So it would not be an
interesting notion.
What you want to have happen
is that the reductions
should be weaker than
the power of the class.
And if you look
at the reductions
that we've defined so far,
they're actually very simple.
The only thing is they
have to make sure that they
can make the output big enough.
But actually
constructing the output,
they're very simple
transformations.
In fact, even polynomial time
is more than you typically need.
There's even much
more limited classes
that are capable of doing
the reductions, as we'll see.
So having powerful
reductions is really
not in the spirit of what
reductions are all about.
You want very, very
simple transformations
to be the reductions.
Anyway, I hope that's helpful.
So what we're going to be
aiming for in the second part
of the lecture is showing
that TQBF is PSPACE complete.
And let me-- here
is the check in.
So this is our first
check in, coming
a little late in the lecture.
Suppose we have proven
that, as we will,
that TQBF is PSPACE complete.
What can we conclude if TQBF is
actually not necessarily in P,
only goes to NP?
And this is relevant
to a question that's
coming in from the chat,
but I'll answer that later.
So suppose TQBF
ends up being an NP
and not in P. What
can we conclude?
Remember, if TQBF
is in P, then PSPACE
equals P. Suppose it goes to NP.
What happens then?
There may be several
correct answers here.
Check all that apply.
All right, so we're near
the end of the poll.
So let me give you
another 10 seconds
and then we're going
to shut it down.
OK, are we all in?
Closing it down.
Here are the results.
So yes, so first of all, the
most reasonable solution,
most reasonable answer is
b, which I think most of you
have gotten.
That if a PSPACE complete
problem goes down to NP,
well, NP is capable of
simulating the polynomial time
reduction.
And so any other
problem in PSPACE
would then also be in NP.
And PSPACE would equal NP.
But note if PSPACE
equals NP, they're
also NP equals coNP,
because PSPACE itself is
closed under complementation.
So that was kind of a
little bit extra fact
that you could conclude
from this as well.
So let's move on then
to our coffee break,
and we'll pick up the proof
that TQBF is PSPACE complete
after that.
So was d true or not?
D was P equal NP.
No, we cannot conclude that
P equals NP from PSPACE equal
to NP.
So if TQBF is in NP, it
doesn't tell us anything.
For all we know, P equals NP.
But from the stuff
that we know so far,
we cannot conclude
that P equals NP.
Oh, and yeah, so you can
conclude-- oh, I'm sorry.
B and d are both correct here.
Let me just shut this thing off.
So b and d are correct.
So if a PSPACE complete
problem goes to NP,
then NP equals
PSPACE, N equals coNP.
So the correct answer, b and d.
Sorry.
I got myself confused.
But c is not something
you can conclude or a.
So somebody is asking
me a fair question.
I say the reduction
method should be weaker
than the class.
But for example, even
in the case of PSPACE,
PSPACE might be
equal to P. And then
it wouldn't be
weaker than the class
if we use polynomial
time reductions.
But I think maybe I should
say apparently weaker.
As far as we know, it's weaker.
But we believe it to be weaker.
It's true if P equals PSPACE,
then every problem in P
is going to be PSPACE complete.
It's just going to be a weird
world if P equals PSPACE.
Same thing for NP and NP.
So I'm getting a
number of questions
also about other
possible reducibilities
that are even weaker than
polynomial time reducibility.
So we're going to see
very soon weaker reduce--
complexity classes within
P. So first of all, PSPACE
seems to be bigger
than P. We're also
going to look at log space.
But that's going to be
actually in Thursday's lecture.
These are classes that
seem to be inside.
Well, they're
inside P. We believe
they're properly inside P.
But we'll see that later.
Let me just see here.
So we're almost out of time.
Let me put our timer back.
In fact, our timer is
showing us out of time.
So why don't we get going?
Let me move this back to--
OK.
Continuing.
TQBF is PSPACE complete.
So first of all,
let's remember TQBF.
These are all of the quantified
Boolean formulas that are true.
So TQBF stands for True
Quantified Boolean Formulas.
And remember, we
saw these examples
from the previous lecture that
these are two quantified--
these are two QBFs.
The first one is true.
The second one is false.
And it's going to be
interesting to think about.
Here they're exactly
the same except
for the order of
the quantifiers.
And so what's really
going on here?
I think it's good to
understand these expressions.
They come up everywhere in
mathematics, these quantifiers.
In the upper one, when
we say for every x,
there exists a y, that y can
depend on the choice of x.
You choose to make
a different x.
You're allowed to
pick a different y.
But the lower expression
says there's a universal y.
There's one particular y
that works for every x.
So in a sense, the
lower statement
is a stronger statement.
Whatever you have in the
quantifier free part.
So the lower one
implies the upper one.
Happens that the lower
one in this case is false
and the upper one is true.
But in general, when
you have this change
of quantifiers like
this, the lower one
would imply the upper one.
Anyway, that's sort
of a side remark.
So let's get back to the proof
that TQBF is PSPACE complete.
That's what our goal is.
All right.
Now, as I mentioned,
this is the same proof.
You're going to be seeing
it for the third time today.
But there's a certain amount
of-- it's sort of the context
changes in each case.
So now we want to show that
TQBF is PSPACE complete.
So it's one of these
hardest problems
now but for PSPACE,
where satisfiability
was the hardest problem for NP.
So we want to show that
every language in PSPACE
is reducible to TQBF.
And so we're going to give
polynomial time reductions
that map some particular problem
a, which can be done in space n
to the k.
It's a problem
solvable in PSPACE.
We're going to show
how f maps a to TQBF.
We have to construct the f.
So f is going to be a
mapping that map strings
which may or may not be in a.
So strings w, which may or may
not be in a, to these formulas,
these quantified formulas.
So w is going to get mapped
to some formula phi sub mw.
It had exactly the
same even symbols
we used when the proof of
the Cook-Levin theorem about
SAT being NP complete.
This is a very similar proof.
But you'll see that we have
to do something more in order
to make it work in this case.
So w is in a if and only if this
formula is going to be in TQBF.
In other words, if and only
if this formula is true.
So this formula is going
to kind of express the fact
that m accepts w,
which means that w
is in a, because
m is the machine,
is the PSPACE machine for a.
So this formula
says m accepts w,
and it achieves that by building
in a simulation of m on w.
It kind of describes a
simulation for m on w
which ends up accepting.
And if m does not accept
w, that description
is going to inevitably be false.
So let's just see what
that's going to look like.
So we're going to
use the same idea
that we used for the
Cook-Levin theorem
that SAT is NP complete.
This notion of a tableau.
So if you remember,
it was basically
a table which was just
simply a way of writing down
a computation
history for m on w.
So the rows are the
steps of the machine.
The top row is the
start configuration.
The bottom row is, let's
say, some particular accept
configuration such as
I just described where
the machine clears its tapes and
moves its head to the left end.
So there's only one
accepting configuration
we have to worry about.
And each of the rows here
is a configuration of m.
Because m runs in
space into the k,
the tableau kind of similarly
to what I described before
has width n to the k.
So now we're talking about
polynomial time machines.
So the f, which is the
bound, the space bound,
is going to be some
polynomial n to the k.
So the width of this
tableau, the size
of these configurations
are going to be n to the k.
How high is this
tableau going to be?
Well, that's going to be
limited by the possible running
time of the machine, which is
similar to what we saw before.
It's going to be exponential
in the space bound.
So it's going to be d
to the n to the k, where
d is essentially the tape
alphabet of the machine.
So are we all together on this?
This is very similar to the
proof of SAT is NP complete.
The key difference there
was m was non-deterministic,
which might be something
to think about later.
But let's not focus
on that right now.
This m is deterministic.
But the important difference
was the shape of the tableau.
The size of the tableau
was very different.
In the case of SAT
is NP complete,
we started off with a polynomial
time non-deterministic machine.
So it only could run for a
polynomial number of steps.
Here is a polynomial
space machine,
which can run for an
exponential number of steps.
That's going to be an
important difference here.
So let's see why.
The reduction has to
construct this formula phi
sub of mw, which basically
says that this tableau exists.
Now, we already saw
how to do that when
we proved the Cook-Levin
theorem that SAT is NP complete.
Remember, we had all of those.
We had variables for each
cell that told us what
the contents of that cell was.
And then we had a
lot of logic here.
We had a bunch of
logic that said
that all those
neighborhoods were correct,
which basically says that
the tableau corresponds
to a correct computation
of the machine.
So why don't we just
do the same thing?
Why don't we just
build our formula
using exactly the
same process that we
used to build the formula when
we had SAT being NP complete?
Something goes wrong.
We can't quite do that.
The problem is that if
you remember the formula
that we built before was really
about as big as the tableau is.
Because it had some logic
for each one of the cells.
It had a set of some
of the variables
for each one of the cells
and it had some logic
for each of those
neighborhoods, basically.
So it says that each of the
cells does the right thing.
So it was a pretty big formula,
but it was still polynomial.
The problem is that tableau is
now n to the k by d to the n
to the k.
That's an exponentially
big object.
So if your formula is going
to be as big as the tableau,
there's no way you can hope
to produce that formula
in polynomial time.
And that's the problem.
The formula is
going to be too big.
Remember, we're trying
to get a polynomial time
reduction from this language a.
So we have an input
to a, a string that
might be an a, which is
simulating the machine.
And the size of the
tableau relative to w
is going to be
something enormous.
And so the formula is
as big as the tableau.
There's no way to produce that
formula in polynomial time.
So this is not going to work.
Let's try again.
So now we have here--
now, so remember this notation
from ci to cj in b steps.
So we're going to give a general
way of constructing formulas
which express this
fact that I can
get from configuration i of
m to configuration j of m
in b steps.
Whatever that b is. b is
going to be some bound.
And I want to know can I
get from this configuration
to that configuration.
And I want to write that
down as a formula, which
is going to express that fact.
And it'll be either
true or false.
And I'm going to give you
a recursive construction
for this formula.
So I'm going to build
that formula for a value
b out of formulas for
smaller values of b.
So this is going to be
a way of constructing
that formula in terms
of other formulas
that I'm going to build.
And there's going to be
a basis for the recursion
when b equals 1.
So that's the big picture.
So let's see how does
this formula look.
So let's not worry about the
case for b equal 1 right now.
This is the case for
larger values of b.
So the fact that I can get
from ci to cj within b steps.
I'm going to write
this down in this way.
And let's try to unpack that
and see what it's saying.
Without worrying about how are
we going to carry this out,
let's just try to understand
at a high level of semantics
of this thing what it's
trying to say to you.
It's going to say, well, I can
get from ci to cj in b steps.
So m can get from
ci to cj in b steps.
If there is some
other configuration c
mid, some other
configuration, I'm
calling it c mid, very much
inspired by the previous proof
of Savitch's
theorem, where there
was c mid was that
intermediate configuration.
So now instead of trying
them all, I'm saying
does there exist one
where I can get from ci
to c mid in half
the number of steps
and from c mid to cj in
half the number of steps?
So if I can build
these two formulas,
then I can combine them with
this sort of extra stuff
out here, and them together,
and put an exist quantifier
that says, does there exist
some configuration, some way
to find a configuration
such that it works
as these formulas require?
If I can do that, then
I'm going to be good.
Because then I can--
well, good.
At least I'll be good in
terms of making something
that is going to work.
So first of all,
let's understand
what I mean by writing down
does there exist c mid.
It's really if
you're thinking back
to the way we did the
Cook-Levin theorem,
we represented
these configurations
by variables which were
indicator variables for each
of the cells.
And we're going to do
exactly the same thing.
So we're going to have a
bunch of Boolean variables
which are going to represent
some configuration.
So more formally, or
in more detail, what
this does, there
exists a c mid, really
is an assignment to all
of those variables that
represent the contents of the
cells of that configuration.
OK, so now let's see how to--
how will the recursion work?
So to get this value
here, I'm going
to do the recursion further.
So does there exist a c mid?
And now for getting
from ci to this c mid,
is there some other c mid?
This is like another value of
w from the previous slide where
I'm getting, again, I'm cutting
the number of steps in half
again.
So going from b over 2
steps to b over 4 steps.
And I'm going to do the
same thing over here.
So I'm just unraveling
the construction
of this formula in
terms of building--
by building it up recursively.
And then I'm just going to keep
doing that until I get down
to the case where b equals 1.
And if I'm now trying to make
a formula that's going to be,
say I can get from ci to
cj in just a single step.
So this is really
talking about a tableau
of height 1 or height 2.
Then I can just directly
write that down the way
I-- now the tableau
is not very big.
So now I can write that
down using the neighborhoods
and so on that I did in the
Cook-Levin theorem proof.
And this is how you
put it all together.
And now if you want to
talk about the getting from
does m accept w.
So I initially say, can I get
from the start configuration
to the accept configuration
in t steps, which
is the maximum running
time of the machine?
So again.
And if you followed me, what
happened in Savitch's theorem,
it's the same values.
Now, the thing is we
have to understand
how big this formula is.
And if you think it
through, there's a problem.
Because what's going on here?
I'm expressing this formula
in terms of formulas
where the size of
b is cut in half.
But now there are two of them.
So it's two formulas
on half the value of b.
That's not going to
be a recursion that's
going to work in our favor.
So let's just see what happens.
So each recursive level
doubles the number of formulas.
Here we have two formulas.
Here we're going to have
four formulas and so on.
So the number of formulas
doubles each time.
So the length of the thing
that we're writing down
is doubling in size each time
we go down the recursion.
That's going to be OK if we
don't go too many levels.
But unfortunately, we are
going quite a few levels,
because the number
of levels is going
to be log of this initial
exponential size thing.
So it's going to be
n to the k levels.
And so if you're doubling
something n to the k times,
you're going to end up with an
exponentially sized formula.
And again, we failed.
OK, so I have a
check in on this.
But maybe we should
spend a couple
of minutes just
trying to understand
what's going on here.
Because the next slide
is really my last slide,
and it's going to
fix this problem.
But let's make sure we
understand what the problem is
before we try to fix it.
Why can we no longer write over
each layer of the recursion
as we did in ladder?
Oh, that's kind of
a cool question.
What does it even mean to write
over the different-- well,
so that's kind of an
interesting question here.
So in a sense, that's
going to be the solution.
We're going to reuse
things in a certain way.
But I want you to understand
that this method itself
does not work, because
this recursion here where
I'm writing the
formula, I'm building
the formula for
b out of formulas
for smaller values of b.
If I do it that way,
I'm going to end up--
if I do it as it's described
in this procedure here,
I'm going to end up with an
exponentially big formula.
And that's not good enough.
So if you cut the formula
in half each time,
even though you
have two formulas,
won't the length be the same?
I'm not cutting the
formula in half.
I'm cutting the
value of b in half.
So you have to
say b is initially
an exponentially big value.
So we're going to end up with
an exponentially big formula.
So it's not really cutting
the formula in half.
Cutting the b in half.
b starts out big.
I mean, b is initially
this value here,
d to the n to the k.
I'm worried.
Not too many questions here.
I have a feeling that's
probably not a good sign.
Well, I mean, if you're
hopelessly confused,
maybe I can't fix it quickly.
So anyway, why don't we move
on and see how to repair this,
how to fix this problem.
And that is going
to be by a trick.
In fact, I know the
people who were involved
with coming up with this.
This was actually, this proof
was done originally at MIT
many years ago in the 1970s.
And the folks who
were involved with it
called it the
abbreviation trick.
So that's what we're going
to do on the next slide.
Oh no, there's a check in first.
Why shouldn't we be surprised
that this construction fails?
A, well, we can't--
just the notion of defining
a quantified Boolean formula
by using recursion
is just not allowed.
So you can't define
formulas that way.
Doesn't use the for all
quantifier anywhere.
Or because we know that TQBF is
not in P. You can see we do--
what do you think?
Why should we not be surprised?
I guess I could have
put a d in there.
Not surprised because you
don't know what's going on.
That's another reason
not to be surprised.
But anyway, hopefully
you have some glimmer
of what's happening here.
And why don't we just--
almost finished.
So I'm going to shut
this down in a second.
Last call.
OK, ending.
All right.
So in fact, the
right answer is b.
I mean, one should be suspicious
that if there's no for alls
appearing in this
construction anywhere.
So really what
we're doing is we're
constructing a formula that
has only exist qualifiers.
So it's a
satisfiability problem.
So really what we just
did was we constructed--
we did in a more complicated
way the Cook-Levin construction,
because we end up
with a SAT formula
only with exist quantifiers.
And so really try one and
try two were the same.
So it's not surprising
that you end up
with an exponentially
big formula as a result.
I don't know.
A lot of you answered
we know that TQBF
is in P. It's not in
P. We don't know that.
I don't know where you--
what's happening with you guys?
But no.
Maybe that was a protest vote.
But anyway, we don't know that.
And what has that got to
do with anything anyway?
So anyway, let's see.
We solve this in our
remaining few minutes here.
So here is the solution.
Remember, this part where we're
saying we're trying to find c
mid, does there
exist a c mid such
that I can get from ci to c
mid in half the number of steps
and c mid to cj in half
the number of steps.
I'm expressing one formula
in terms of two formulas.
That's where the
blow up is occurring.
Because these two are then
in terms are going to each--
so these two are going to
become 4, become 8, and that's
not good.
Can I express this fact in
terms of just one formula?
And this kind of a little bit in
the spirit of your suggestions.
Can we kind of reuse
things in a way?
And that's what we're
actually going to kind do.
So here's another way
of saying the same thing
but with just a single formula.
And it uses a for all.
And the idea behind
it is that an and
is kind of like a for all.
Or a for all is
kind of like an and.
Just like in exist as
kind of like an or.
So when you're saying
does something exist,
is it this thing or that thing
or that thing or that thing?
And when you're
saying for all, it
has this thing and that thing
and that thing and that thing.
Ands and for alls are
very much related.
And so we're going to convert
this and into a for all.
We're going to say for all
configuration cg and ch that
are either set to ci c mid or
to c mid cj, the formula cg ch--
I can get from cg to ch in
half the number of steps.
So you have to think about
what this is meaning here.
And I also want to
make sure that you
don't feel I'm cheating you,
because well, first of all,
so now we have just
a single formula.
We're going to go down
to the case b equals 1,
as we did before.
You have to make sure that
saying this restricted for all
is not a cheat.
When you have for all x is
in s, like we have over here,
is equivalent to saying for
all x if x happens to be in s,
then the other thing follows.
And this implication can be
expressed using ands and ors.
And as before, the
initial starting point
is going to be going from c
start to c accept in t steps.
And so the analysis
that we get is
that because there's
no longer a blow up,
each recursive level just
adds this stuff here in front.
The exist c mid and
this for all part.
So that's going to be adding
order n to the formula instead
of multiplying because
we have two formulas.
And now the total number of
levels is order n to the k,
as before.
So the size is going to be n to
the k times n to the k order n
to the 2k.
I actually I had a
brief check in here,
which I'd like you to do just
in our remaining few seconds.
Does this construction depend
on m being deterministic?
So let me just launch that.
I want you to guys to get
your check in credit here.
But in fact, you have
to think this through.
That formula says that the
tableau, you get a tableau.
Is that going to
matter depending
upon whether it's deterministic
or non-deterministic?
It's actually, well, it's
kind of running 50/50 here.
Why don't you just
pick something?
Because I'd like to just
close this out and just
get to our last slide.
So if you don't
follow, don't worry.
But it's actually an interesting
point that the fact that this--
so I'm going to end this.
All in?
So in fact, the right
answer is it still would
work if it's non-deterministic.
And this would give
you an alternative way
of proving Savitch's theorem.
So really this all comes
down to this proof,
which implies Savitch's
theorem and then in turn
implies the ladder DFA problem.
So anyway, that's side note,
not critical for understanding,
really.
You can take those as all
separate, the results,
and that's good enough.
All right, so coming back.
Whoops.
Coming back.
This is what we did.
And so each recursive
level, the size of the QBF
is not the same.
Somebody's asking is it the
same at each recursive level.
No, we had to add in--
let's just see.
Each recursion.
This is recursively
built here, but now we
have to add this part in front
and this part here in front.
So the quantifier
which is quantified
over a bunch of
variables representing
the configuration, that
gets added on at each level.
So it's not just
it stays the same.
There's stuff
that's get added in.
But what's important is that it
doesn't blow up exponentially.
The stuff gets added in every
time but not multiplied.
OK.
So we're done here.
So anybody, you
can all take off.
I think many of
you already have.
Bye bye.
Thank you.